Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, ich hab gehört die Telekom will uns jetzt die Katzenbilder wegnehmen und Podcast langsam mal abspielen.
Tim, für schlechte Witze musst du Spezialdienst buchen.
Ja, hallo. Willkommen bei eurem Lieblingspodcast noch in der Normalgeschwindigkeit. Zu 100 Prozent wird hier alles wiedergegeben, so wie ihr es gewohnt seid. Mal schauen, wie lange das noch so bleibt. Boah, wir Katzenbilder sind in Gefahr. Sag ich jetzt mal so. Hast du eine gute Woche gehabt?
Ich bin verärgert.
Du möchtest gerne Benzin auf dein Laptop gießen und anzünden, damit du wieder gute Laune hast, stimmt's?
Ja, aber du gibst mir keinen Sprit.
Ja, weißt du, vielleicht brennt ja auch die Club-Marte.
Nee, habe ich ja schon versucht.
So das Hackermolli brennt leider nicht.
Ich bin irgendwie mit der allgemeinen Nachrichtenlage unzufrieden.
Ja, ich auch. Ich finde es nicht erfreulich. Das Unerfreulichste ist, dass wir unser Intro noch nicht in einer Moll-Variante haben.
Ja, das ist echt...
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Da würde ich nochmal beigehen.
Ja, die Lampe flackert.
Ja, die Lampe flackert. Das Internet fällt schon langsam auseinander. Es ist dramatisch. Dramatische Szenen spielen sich ab in der Metaebene. Ja, ich verstehe deinen Ärger und ich teile ihn und ich fühle ihn auch. Das war jetzt mal nicht schön, wenn auch absehbar. Ich möchte jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt komplett überrollt dastehen und uns sagen, wie konnte das nur passieren? Und wir fühlten uns doch schon auf dem Regenbogen. Da sind wir dann realist genug, oder?
Du redest hier von Katzenbildern und von Realität. Hat doch mit Internet nichts zu tun, Realität. Das ist ja alles virtuell.
Genau. Lass uns doch einfach mal in die Nachrichtenlage einsteigen.
Fass, es gibt zum ersten Mal seit Gedenken der Menschheit Neuigkeiten, die sowohl gut für Konzerne sind, als auch für die Interessen von Konsumenten. Das erste Mal seit Gedenken der Menschheit, dass so etwas geschehen ist. Ja, hat mir Günther Oettinger gepwittert. Ach, zum ersten Mal, dass es gute Nachrichten für beide gibt. Für Konsumenten und Konzerne.
Kaltschweig und Western sozusagen. Das ist ja geil. Das ist doch super. Ich gucke noch mal in den Kühlschrank, ob er noch eine Säckflasche hat.
Genau.
Das ist der Ausgleich der Interessen. So läuft das.
Ich greiche gleich mein Interesse auf.
Das ist schön, dass wir solche engagierten Politiker haben, die sich alle Argumente anhören und dann mit so kreativen Lösungen am Start sind.
Also bei mir, weil mir die Objektivität und Ruhe fehlte, dieses Thema noch einmal in Ruhe besonnen aufzurollen, habe ich gestern Thomas angerufen und habe ihn das erklären lassen.
Wir sollten aber erstmal erklären, was das Thema überhaupt ist. Es geht um den Beschluss des Europäischen Parlaments, was wir auch angekündigt hatten, dass das ansteht. Den finalen Beschluss um die Position des Europäischen Parlaments im Rahmen der Trilog-Verhandlung der EU zum Thema Netzneutralität und Roaming und was halt noch alles in diesem Paket so drin war. Und diese Abstimmung ist jetzt am Dienstag erfolgt und es hätte noch alles gut werden können, hätte denn eine Mehrheit der Parlamentarier für vier Änderungsanträge gestimmt. Das haben wir ja hier in der letzten Sendung auch alles nochmal ausführlich dargelegt. Spoiler, haben sie nicht. Es fand sich keine nennenswerte Mehrheit und dementsprechend geht das Papier jetzt im Prinzip so, wie es vorher schon vorlag und das ist halt im Wesentlichen der Entwurf des Rates. Sprich sozusagen der europäischen Regierung. So geht er dann jetzt eben in die letzte Runde und es ist halt davon auszugehen, dass jetzt dieses Paket so beschlossen wird. Ja und da Thomas ja da extrem engagiert war in dem ganzen Kampf, das Ruder noch rumzureißen, gab ja auch schon mal bessere Zeiten, dass wir ihnen mal ein bisschen zu Wort kommen.
Thomas, was ist schief gegangen?
Gute Frage. Also wir haben es nicht geschafft, eine absolute Mehrheit für unsere Änderungsanträge zu bekommen. Also der Text, der jetzt gesetzt wird, ist der, der schon im Trilog ausverhandelt wurde. Über den haben wir eh schon mal gesprochen. Der ist halt extrem zweideutig. Netzneutralität, da geht es ja im Kern darum, dass man Internet-Providern verbieten will, im Internet zu diskriminieren. Und diesen Diskriminierungsschutz, den haben wir jetzt halt nur mit großen Lücken. Und deswegen wird die eigentliche Entscheidung, wie dieser mehrdeutige Text jetzt zu verstehen ist, von der Politik auf die Regulierungsbehörden und auf die Gerichte abgewälzt. Das heisst, wir haben mal Rechtsunsicherheit und der Kampf ist jetzt mal von der politischen Bühne weg. Wir waren dann auf einer anderen Ebene und es gibt noch ganz viel zu sagen. Es geht auf jeden Fall noch weiter auch, aber jetzt mal so von dem Gesetzgebungsprozess her sind wir ans Ende gekommen und der Text wird jetzt so wahrscheinlich schon im November gesetzt werden und tritt dann immer ab April in Kraft.
Auf einer Skala von eins bis irgendwie Vollkatastrophe, wie schlimm ist es denn jetzt? Also große Lücken, es klingt irgendwie komisch, klingt nach okay, es gibt große Lücken, aber es gibt auch ein Grundgerüst. Also was haben wir denn zum Beispiel, was haben wir denn jetzt mal unveränderlich wirklich wenigstens? Was ist das Wenige, was wir jetzt haben?
Also was wir auf jeden Fall jetzt haben, ist, das Blockieren von Diensten wird es nicht mehr geben. Also wir kennen, dass im Mobilfunk, dass Skype über die AGBs ausgeschlossen wird, das geht nicht mehr mit diesem Text. Auch das beliebige Throttling von Dienstklassen wird schwieriger. Das geht aber immer noch. Also vor allem Filesharing und VPNs drosseln, das ist sogar ein neues Problem. Das wird es weiterhin geben. Und Zero-Rating, also der Spotify-Deal von der deutschen Telekom, das bleibt offen. Da wird es wirklich spannend, wie es mit Zero-Rating weitergeht, weil da ist die Verordnung am unklarsten. Spezialdienste eigentlich auch. Bei Spezialdiensten wird es auch so sein, dass wir das kann man so oder so lesen. Ich sage mal, ich bin nicht glücklich damit. Ich würde diesem Gesetz nicht zustimmen. Deswegen haben wir auch dagegen gekämpft. Aber ja, ich meine, am Ende, das Roaming war halt ein genialer Schachzug. Deswegen ist das Gesetz jetzt auch durchgegangen. Ohne Roaming hätten wir wahrscheinlich noch weiter verhandeln können. Und so weit werden wir gekommen, dass wir vielleicht ein ordentliches Gesetz haben. Das ist leider nicht passiert.
Und da würde mich jetzt noch mal interessieren, wie ist das jetzt mit diesem Gesetz eigentlich gelaufen? Das ging ja schon vor ungefähr zwei Jahren los mit Nelly Cruz, die gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt mal Netzneutralität. Die wusste aber nie genau, was das ist.
Genau, Nelly Cruz, man erinnert sich, die hat sogar, wie sie angetreten ist, 2010 hat sie ein kleines Herzchen neben den Tagesordnungspunkten Netzneutralität gemalt. Sie hat alle große Hoffnungen gehabt. Dann hat sie ganz lange nichts gemacht, bis kurz vor der Europawahl und dann hat sie dieses Gesetz vorgestellt, diese Hybris, wo halt endlich drinnen steht, keine Netzneutralität. Also wir schaffen die Netzneutralität ab und legalisieren die Diskriminierung. Dann ist das ins Europaparlament gegangen. Das hat sich sehr ambitioniert mit dem Timotheus.
Das Nelly-Cruz-Ding, der Text, das war doch das, wo sie sagte, in dem offenen Internet muss alles netzneutral sein, aber wir haben halt nochmal das andere Internet. Und da machen wir einfach Sodom und Gomorra. So ungefähr war ja ihr Vorschlag damals, oder?
Na ja, die grundsätzliche Idee, die wir heute immer noch haben, dass man irgendwie so Internet hat und das ist so ein bisschen neutral, die gibt es noch und daneben hat man halt Spezialdienste. Und Spezialdienste, für die gelten andere Regeln, die müssen sich nicht an die Gleichberechtigung halten. Diese Grundidee ist immer noch vorhanden und ich glaube, das ist auch der große Heck dieses Gesetzes. Weil Spezialdienste eigentlich muss man darüber nicht streiten, das ist eine ganz simple Sache, aber es hat ganz viel Energie gefressen und Teile der Debatte aufgeweicht. Die originale Kommissions-Texte war aber schon nochmal ein Stückchen schlimmer. Die haben sich wirklich legistische Schweinereien anfallen lassen, wie innerhalb der Vertragsbedingungen gilt Diskriminierungsfreiheit. Die haben wirklich übelste Tricks da reingebaut, die jetzt so nicht mehr in dem Gesetz drin sind, aber dafür ist es jetzt schwammig. Du hast teilweise Artikel, Anfang und Ende widersprechen sich. Da ist einfach logisch was falsch. Das Parlament hat damals sehr viel repariert, die haben wirklich gute Arbeit geleistet in einer Rekordzeit. Leider ist das Gesetz aber nicht nur über Netzneutralität, sondern auch wegen Roaming. Das war das Wahlversprechen der ganzen Abgeordneten, die wiedergewählt werden wollten im Mai 2014, als wir die letzte Europawahl hatten. Dieser gute Text von damals, den wir auch gefeiert haben, der ist dann halt in den Rat gegangen. Bei den 28 EU-Mitgliedstaaten wurde dann weiterverhandelt und die haben die Zeit zurückgedreht und sich wieder sehr stark an der Kommission orientiert und wiederum einen Text vorgelegt, der mit Netzneutralität nichts mehr zu tun hat. Und da ist dann eben die, dann hat der Trilog begonnen. Dann ist sozusagen der intransparenteste Teil ever, wo die drei EU-Situationen hinter verschlossenen Türen zu einer geheimen Tagesordnung miteinander sprechen. Und wenn man nicht irgendwie Leute gut kennt, dann kriegt man gar nicht mit, worüber gerade verhandelt wird und kann auch keine Stellungnahmen abgeben.
Im Prinzip geht also die Kommissarin zu dem Zeitpunkt, Nelly Cruz, hin, schreibt was, reicht das runter ins Parlament, da schreibt das um und reicht es weiter in den Rat und der schreibt es auch nochmal um.
Genau, dann hast du drei Positionen zu dem Text. Die Kommission kann nur vorlegen, die hat danach zwar Mitspracherecht, aber die hat eine Position. Und dann eben Parlament und Rat bilden sich auch eine eigene Meinung zu dem Text, machen sozusagen ihre Wunschvorstellungen von dem Gesetz und mit diesen drei Wunschvorstellungen gehst du dann in Verhandlungen und versuchst einen Kompromiss zu finden.
Und welche Balances werden jetzt durch diese Kommission, Rat und Parlament gewahrt?
Meinst du, was die Interessen sind, dieser drei EU-Institutionen?
Also was haben sich die Founding Fathers dabei gedacht, dass es jetzt diese drei Institutionen gibt, die dann noch einmal verhandeln sollen? Wir haben ja in dem EU-Parlament mehr oder weniger direkt gewählte Parlamentarier aus den Mitgliedsstaaten. Im Rat haben wir irgendwelche Vertreter der Staaten, die aber nicht direkt dahin gewählt wurden.
Das ist ein ganz guter Punkt. Also das hat sich alles entwickelt. Ich gehe jetzt nicht auf die Historie ein, sondern wie es heute ist. Also du hast die Kommission, das ist eigentlich eine Behörde, mehrere Behörden, mehrere Kommissare, die alle einen Beamtenapparat haben und die verwalten ganz viel. Und die können auch Gesetzesvorschläge starten. Nur die haben das Initiativrecht, also nur die können einen Gesetzgebungsprozess wirklich beginnen. Die anderen können danach viel machen, aber nur die Kommission kann was lostreten. Das Parlament ist eben wie jedes Parlament direkt gewählt, abgeordnete, aber eben fliegende Mehrheiten, freie Mandate, meiner Meinung nach das beste Parlament, das wir in Europa haben. Und dann hast du den Rat und da beginnt schon, weil du hast gerade gesagt, da sitzen dann so Leute aus den Staaten, da sitzen auch wiederum Beamte und Vertreter der Regierung. Also du hast hier eigentlich die Exekutive, die zur Legislative wird, die auch irgendwie an Gesetzen mitschreibt und mitverhandelt und auch sozusagen, wenn das mal vorgelegt wurde, danach noch mal darauf Einfluss nimmt. Und der Rat verhält sich jetzt mal so aus Bürgerrechtsperspektive am schlechtesten, weil die eben sich nicht verantworten müssen gegenüber der Bevölkerung. Wir kennen das doch, ja, das hat die EU entschieden. Dass unsere eigene Regierung, die da gerade mit dem Finger auf Brüssel zeigt, selber am Tisch gesessen ist und das selber mitgetragen hat in vielen Fällen, das sagen sie nicht dazu. Das heißt, die haben ein Verantwortungsdefizit. Die sind noch dazu sehr intransparent. Ich meine, ich bin ja der Meinung, dass dieses ganze Verwirrerspiel habt ihr öfter schon gehabt. Europarat, Rat der Europäischen Union und so, das klingt alles ähnlich und ich glaube, es ist bewusst Nebelgranate, dass man sich halt ja nicht auskennt, wer jetzt gerade politisch handelt. Und der Rat hat hier halt auch eben viele Sachen weggestrichen und bei dem Gesetzgebungsverfahren halt einfach, sag ich jetzt mal, pur die Interessen der Industrie und der Telekomindustrie vertreten. Weil du siehst doch richtig schön die großen Länder, die alle noch Anteile an ihren Telekomfirmen halten, also Deutschland, Deutsche Telekom, Italien, Spanien Telefonica, Großbritannien, British Telekom, die haben sich alle sehr im Interesse der Telekomindustrie verhalten. Weil die haltende Anteile, das bringt Geld ins Budget. Man will dieser eine Branche, die auch immer noch Jobs schafft, die noch gut funktioniert trotz Krise, einfach keine Steine in den Weg legen. Die Telekomindustrie hat mit dem Rat eine perfekte Interessensvertretung, an die man auch so als Zivilgesellschaft fast nicht rankommt.
Dann mal, du kennst mich ja als Advokatus Diabolis. Die EU, ich nenne das jetzt mal weiterhin die EU, geht hin und sagt, Freunde, wir haben ja so ein kleines Wahlversprechen. Wir nehmen euch die Einkünfte aus dem Roaming weg. Da muss man dazu sagen, Roaming ist so eine wunderschöne Cashcow für die Mobilfunknetze, wo sie sich gegenseitig viel Geld in Rechnung stellen. Am Ende des Monats überweisen sie sich natürlich einen Betrag Geld. Du bist als Netz in das Feel geroamt wird, bist du eigentlich ganz gut dran. Dann haben sie auch ihre Verhandlungsbasis. Die haben dann Roaming Agreements untereinander und versuchen das irgendwie wieder aufzuweichen. Aber insgesamt ist das für dich als Mobilfunknetz immer gut, wenn Menschen in dein Netz kommen, die da eigentlich keinen Vertrag haben, weil denen das berechnest du fürstlich. Und genauso berechnest du vielleicht auch als Netz deinen Kunden extra was, wenn sie dein Netz verlassen. Und das ist etwas, was für die eine signifikante Einnahmequelle war. Und jetzt hat die EU sich angeschickt und hat mit Anlauf gesagt, diese Einnahmequelle nehmen wir euch weg. Und dann sind sie ja offenbar hingegangen und haben gesagt, ja, Freunde, wenn ihr uns die wegnehmt, dann müssen wir uns aber wenigstens eine andere Einnahmequelle geben. Und die, die sich da ja eigentlich hinter verbirgt, ist ja die Einnahmequelle. Ich möchte als Internet-Anbieter auch an der anderen Seite meiner Dienstleistungen Geld verdienen. Also ich möchte nicht nur von Thomas Geld dafür nehmen, dass er irgendwie Bits aus dem Internet bekommt, sondern ich möchte auch von Spotify Geld dafür nehmen, dass die Bits ankommen und ich möchte quasi ab einer gewissen Größe meine Kunden, die unter Umständen mehrere Millionen sind, in die Waagschale gegenüber den Inhalteanbietern werfen und sagen, Freunde, schönes Geschäftsmodell, was ihr da habt, wäre doch schade, wenn eure Kunden unzufrieden wären. Das ist doch die ökonomische Erwägung, die da jetzt offenbar auch in der Koppelung dieser beiden Initiativen stattgefunden hat, oder?
Ja, das ist stark zu vermuten, weil, wie gesagt, auf der einen Seite nimmt man ihnen was weg, auf der anderen gibt man ihnen etwas dazu. Die Frage ist jetzt mit dem derzeitigen Roamingtext, wie viel man ihnen überhaupt wegnimmt. Weil was damit mal beschlossen ist, ist nur, dass im April 2016 die Roaminggebühren ein Stückchen fallen. Dann kostet ein Megabyte im Ausland maximal 5 Cent. Das wären sie aber wahrscheinlich sowieso, weil wir sowieso schon in einer Richtung sind, wo Roaminggebühren ständig fallen. Das ist schon seit einigen Jahren so, weil die EU das natürlich schon längst erkannt hat. Wenn du irgendwie Grenzen abbaurst und dann aber nur noch an deinem Telefon merkst, dass du jetzt gerade von Deutschland nach Frankreich fährst, dann ist das nicht im europäischen Gedanken. Also, die Roaminggebühren werden so oder so gefallen. Es ist halt ein klassisch europäisches Thema, womit auch Europapolitiker punkten können. Europa braucht ja gerade auch irgendwie Erfolge aufgrund der vielen anderen Krisen. Aber wie gesagt, ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass ihnen da jetzt wirklich viel weggebrochen ist, was sie nicht sowieso schon eingeplant hatten. Und auch dann im, glaube ich, Juni 2017, wenn jetzt wirklich sozusagen nochmal der zweite Schritt des Roaming-Styles, dieser Verordnung in Kraft tritt, dann könnten die Roaminggebühren ganz fallen. Dazu muss man aber vorher noch eine Studie vorlegen. Jetzt frag mich nicht mehr, weil da weiß ich, das ist selber nicht mein Spezialgebiet, aber das ist alles noch mit Fragezeichen gekennzeichnet, ob wir dann wirklich gar kein Roaming mehr haben werden. Was jetzt schon feststeht, dass du nicht irgendwie von einem skandinavischen Land zum Beispiel dir eine SIM-Karte holen kannst und die dann einfach ganz normal in Deutschland oder Österreich verwenden kannst. Also wirklich dauerhaft mit fremden SIM-Karten in einem Land zu sein und dir einfach den billigsten Tarif europaweit zu holen, das wird nicht gehen. Da hagelt es dann neue Gebühren. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt auch eigentlich die Netzautorität aufgegeben für auch einen nicht wirklich klaren Roaming-Deal. Am Ende haben wir nicht wirklich was gewonnen mit diesem Text.
Also du musst nach wie vor bei einem deutschen oder einem österreichischen, in deinem Heimatland befindlichen Provider den Vertrag machen und solltest die Mehrheit deiner Zeit auch in diesem Land verbringen, sonst treten sie auf den Fuß und sagen, nee, geht so nicht.
Genau. Und wie das jetzt konkret dann alles funktionieren soll, weil das sind so Fair-Use-Klauseln, frag mich nicht. Ich habe auch noch von niemanden gehört, auch nicht von den Konsumentenschutzorganisationen, dass es jetzt irgendwie klare Szenarien gibt, was der Text jetzt da bedeutet. Man könnte fast davon ausgehen, dass er dort genauso schwammig ist wie bei der Netzneutralität. Also das steht irgendwie über dem ganzen Teil. Das sind so zwei populäre Themen. Wir tun was fürs Internet, digital und so, Zukunft und wir schaffen die Roaminggebühren ab. Die Hoffnung war wahrscheinlich, dass keiner genau genug hinschaut und dass sie mit dieser Message durchkommen. Das ist eigentlich schon so ein bisschen der Erfolg, vor allem der letzten Wochen, dass wir es geschafft haben, dass diese Nachricht so nicht durchgekommen ist. Dass Günther Oettinger sich bei der Pressekonferenz heftigst rechtfertigen musste, weil einfach der Narrative klar war, das ist ein fauler Deal. Das ist zumindest bei der Netzneutralität weit weg von dem, was die USA haben. Sie haben immer versucht, zu streuen, dass die EU-Regeln besser wären als die amerikanischen, was nicht stimmt. Und da haben wir ihnen zumindest ihre Suppe versalzen und die Jubelmeldung weggenommen.
Das ist natürlich schön, aber trotzdem schade, wenn wir jetzt mit einem schlechten Gesetz dastehen.
Manöverkritik läuft noch. Die ersten Analysen und Mails gehen rum. Man fängt an nachzudenken, was hätte man besser machen können. In der Historie sind wir vorher stehen geblieben beim Rat. Der Rat hat einen schlechten Text vorgelegt. Der Trilog hat dann einen nicht sagenden Text vorgelegt. Dann sind wir sehr kurzfristig um die Sommerpause dahin gekommen, wo wir heute stehen. Am 15. Juli wurde das Ganze noch mal im Ausschuss beschlossen. Vor der Sommerpause. Und dann jetzt noch mal vor zwei Wochen. Beides Mal im Industrieausschuss. In beiden Mal wurden keine Änderungsanträge zugelassen. Was sehr spannend ist. Man hat zuerst gemeint, beim zweiten Ausschuss kriegt ihr Änderungsanträge. Und dann beim zweiten haben sie gesagt, ihr hättet beim ersten Ausschuss Änderungsanträge stellen können. Das war auch nicht gerade demokratisch. Das Ganze wurde mit rasendem Tempo durchgepeitscht. Wir hatten zwei Wochen zwischen Ausschuss und Plenum. Zwei Wochen, um alles in Stellung zu bringen und zu mobilisieren. Allein in der letzten Woche sind 20.000 Mails rausgegangen von Safety Internet. Wir haben die größten Firmen, die wir kriegen konnten, mobilisiert, also WordPress, Vimeo, Soundcloud und viele andere. Tim Berners-Lee hat sich für Änderungsanträge ausgesprochen, genauso wie Lorenz Lessig und Barbara von Schewick. Wir hatten wirklich von größter Seite Support in den letzten Metern und haben wirklich noch mal viel Wind gemacht. Es gab aber strukturelle Gründe, wegen denen es einfach am Ende nicht funktioniert hat, meiner Meinung nach. Das sind grundsätzliche Ungleichgewichte zwischen den EU-Institutionen.
Die würden mich gleich natürlich sehr genau interessieren. Die andere Frage ist, wenn sich diese drei Institutionen nicht einig sind, dann kommt halt was Nichtsagendes bei raus. Das ist natürlich eigentlich Mist. Eine Nichtsagendes Gesetz oder eine nicht eindeutige Regulation ist ja einfach immer scheiße, oder? Da kannst du besser nichts machen. Das große Problem ist ja jetzt, dass du eigentlich das Thema Netzneutralität auf EU-Ebene, wenn ich jetzt mal vorsichtig was sagen darf, das wird es einfach nie wieder geben. Weil die dir sagen werden, haben wir doch. Wir haben noch Netzneutralität. Das heißt, du wirst das Thema so schnell nicht nochmal an dieser Stelle aufhängen können, oder?
Das werden wir sehen. Also, ich mein, wie gesagt, wir haben ein mehrdeutiges Gesetz. Jetzt gibt es mal den nächsten Schritt, dass die Regulierungsbehörden hergehen und sagen, okay, wir machen das konkret. Wir brauchen was, um arbeiten zu können. Und wir machen jetzt Guidelines und die werden klar sein, mit denen kann dann die Regulierungsbehörde entscheiden, machen wir hier was, verbieten wir einen Spotify-Deal von der Deutschen Telekom oder lassen wir den bleiben. Die Fragen sind jetzt noch nicht geklärt. Die kommen dann erst später. Genauso, was ist ein Spezialdienst, das wissen wir jetzt noch nicht. Das werden wir dann später wissen. Diese konkreten Sachen, die hängen auch davon ab, wie die Regulierungsbehörden in den einzelnen Mitgliedsstaaten so drauf sind. Ob die sagen, ja, natürlich, Netzvertralität ist wichtig, wir wollen hier was tun, wie zum Beispiel die Österreicher, oder ob die so drauf sind wie die Bundesnetzagentur, die halt so, was, Netzvertralität? Nein, das brauchen wir nicht. Das sind ja eh alle so kleine Eingriffe. Da profitiert der Nutzer ja davon. Dann werden wir sehr unterschiedliche Erfahrungen sammeln in den einzelnen Mitgliedsstaaten, die genau gemonitert werden müssen. Und dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch Gerichtsprozesse geben, also wenn Regulierungsbehörden wie die Österreicher dann wirklich sagen, wir machen was, wir verbieten den Spotify-Deal von Hutchinson 3 in Österreich, dann wird Hutchinson 3 natürlich dagegen klagen. Und die werden bis zum EuGH ziehen. Und dann wird der Gerichtshof eigentlich erst das unklare Gesetz genau auslegen. Weil der EuGH muss auch wieder klare Fakten schaffen. Und das kann aber Jahre dauern. Jahre der Rechtsunsicherheit, wo ich jetzt auch, die Stimme hatten wir ja auch, so Wagnis Kapitalgeber, Venture Capitalist, die in Startups investieren, die haben vorher auch schon gesagt, Leute, wenn ihr dieses Gesetz macht, dann hören wir auf, in Europa zu investieren. Weil wieso unterstütze ich ein Geschäftsmodell, von dem ich nicht weiß, ob es in einem Jahr noch funktionieren wird? Diese ganze Kritik, die ist schon auch angekommen. Und es gibt schon erste Aussagen, vor allem von Günter Oettinger, dass man offen ist für eine Reparatur. Ich habe Günter Oettinger ja am Freitag in München getroffen. Und das war mehr oder weniger das, was er mir da erzählt hat. Also er hat mir ein Gesprächsangebot gemacht und mir Honig ums Maul geschmiert und eben auch gesagt, wenn es da Probleme gibt, dann werden wir nachbessern. Und jetzt müssen wir das Gesetz aber so durchbringen. Und dieselbe Aussage hat er aber auch gestern im Deutschlandfunk getätigt, dass die Kommission bereit ist, da in Reparaturen zu gehen, wenn es wirklich zu Problemen kommt. Jetzt müssen wir halt nachweisen, dass es auch Probleme gibt. Das heißt, das Thema Netzeutrality ist eigentlich bei weitem nicht beendet, sondern jetzt geht es erst richtig los und jetzt geht es in die mühsame Kleinarbeit. In 28 Ländern.
Ich freue mich ja zumindest, dass du nicht völlig am Boden zerstört bist, nachdem du dir mit dem Thema über so viele Jahre so viel Mühe gegeben hast und bis zum Ende gefiebert und gekämpft hast.
Wenn man einmal ein Thema findet, das nicht langweilig wird, dann muss man dranbleiben. Aber ich hätte auch gerne irgendwie, also wäre das in Europa gut gegangen, dann hätte ich mich halt mehr am internet.org gekümmert und Zero Rating in Global South. Aber ja, also ich meine, wir müssen da jetzt einfach dranbleiben. Ich meine, der einzige Hoffnungsschimmer ist, selber lachen, wenn ich das sage, aber die USA haben halt auch zwei Anläufe gebraucht. Die ersten FCC-Regeln waren auch scheiße. Nur für Festnetze und nicht für Mobilfunk. Und haben Zero Rating auch gar nicht berührt. Jetzt haben wir bessere Regeln. Vielleicht brauchen wir in der EU auch zwei Anläufe und sind einfach hinten nach. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich werde auf jeden Fall versuchen, dem Thema treu zu bleiben. Aber was wir auch gesehen haben, ist, wir sind viel zu wenig Leute. Das Kernteam von Safety Internet sind am Ende halt auch, kann man vielleicht dann ein bis zwei Händen abzählen. Da braucht es einfach viel mehr Menschen, die mitmachen mit ihren Skills. Seien das jetzt Entwickler, Designer, Kommunikationsmenschen. Also da müssen wir professioneller und besser werden, damit wir wirklich eine Chance haben.
Wie ist denn jetzt Safety Internet? Wie hat die Kampagne verfangen? Also offenbar von den Parlamentariern war keiner mehr, oder die Leute waren nicht ernsthaft mehr zu beeindrucken. Wie viele Anrufe gemacht wurden, kannst du glaube ich nicht sehen. Oder konntest du jetzt gerade nicht einsehen?
Kann ich nicht sehen. Das sind Zahlen, die la quadratura di nette vorlegen müssten. Die machen dieses Pipeform-Tool.
Dann schauen wir mal nächste Woche, ob ich das rausfinde. Aber Mails wurden fünfstellig verschickt, hast du gesagt?
Ja, ich habe nur die Zahlen von der letzten Woche da. Das waren 20.600, die mit PIVIC gezählt wurden. Ich sehe jetzt gerade die aktuelle Woche nicht. Aber wir haben natürlich am Montag nochmal ganz viel gepusht. Aber eher eben auf Telefon, weil so kurzfristig sind Anrufe einfach besser. Ich habe dir eh in der letzten Sendung schön gesagt, man kann halt diese E-Mails nicht wegsortieren. Also meine Vermutung war, dass viele Abgeordnete einen einfachen Filter hatten auf Netzneutralität. Und da gab es sogar schon Memes dazu, die innerhalb vom Parlament zirkuliert sind, weil wir halt wirklich wieder stark waren. Und wir haben keine Faxe mehr verschickt, weil die eben auf elektronischen Faxversand umgestellt haben, wahrscheinlich auch wegen uns. Was aber wirklich gut funktioniert hat, waren die Anrufe. Aber auch wir hatten dann aus den USA auch noch mal Unterstützung. Battle for the Net, die Seite, die in den USA ganz massiv Campaign gemacht hat, die hat uns unterstützt. Die haben selber eine eigene E-Mail-Kampagne und ich glaube sogar Telefonkampagne laufen gehabt. Also da wurde schon viel in Bewegung gesetzt nochmal. Und man hat schon richtig gemerkt, dass das auch bei den Leuten ankam. Aber am Ende waren halt auch die Gespräche, die ich dann noch im Montag in Straßburg im Europaparlamenten habe, auch mit den Leuten gesprochen, die dann nicht für uns gestimmt haben. Und was ich da halt oft gehört habe, ist, klar kommt an, ich verstehe die Argumente, ich gebe euch sogar inhaltlich recht, ich finde die Änderungsanträge sogar gut, aber wenn wir diesen Deal jetzt nicht akzeptieren, dann springt uns der Rat ab. Wir haben einfach nur die eine Möglichkeit, diesen einen Text anzunehmen, und wenn wir da nicht ja und amen sagen, dann sagt der Rat, pff, ich brauch keine Roaming-Abschaffung, ich brauch keine Netzhäutralität. Dann lassen wir das Gesetz sterben. Und mit der Angst, mit dem Argument, ist die Mehrheit zustande gekommen gegen uns. Das war sowohl bei Konservativen und auch ganz stark bei Sozialdemokraten so. Und das ist ein wirklich teufisches Argument, weil damit kann der Rat immer diktieren, was durchgeht und was nicht. Damit definiert der Rat die roten Linien. Und das Parlament macht in erster Lesung sehr bürgerrechtsfreundliche Texte. Man denke an die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, die Jan-Philipp Albrecht gerade verhandelt. Und dann kommt der Rat und sagt, nein, aber nicht mit uns. Und mit uns gibt es nur das und das. Und wenn das Parlament da nicht sich auf die Hinterbeine stellt und sagt, wir sind hier direkt demokratisch legitimiert und wir vertreten zu allererst die Interessen der Bevölkerung, dann werden wir da immer wieder in dieselben Probleme reinlaufen. Und da müssen wir strukturell was ändern. Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, wie man das machen kann. Mehr Öffentlichkeit für Europathemen ist auf jeden Fall notwendig. Und halt einfach auch die Staaten in die Verantwortung nehmen für die Position, die sie im Rat vertreten. Wie gesagt, Deutschland hat im Thema Netzneutralität im Rat noch mal eine viel schlechtere Position vertreten als die, die sie national schon haben.
Und was wären deine Vorschläge, das jetzt zu ändern?
Naja, dem Parlament irgendwie klarzumachen, dass es sich emanzipieren muss. Das ist die einzige Organisation, wo dieses Europa wirklich funktioniert. Wo einerseits mal sachlich die besten Entscheidungen getroffen werden, soweit ich das in meinem Themenfeld dann überblicken kann, aber auch eben die Bürgernähe noch am ersten gegeben ist. Wie gesagt, im Rat darf verhandeln Beamte. Im besten Fall werden große Themen zwischen den Innenministern oder Verkehrsministern mal ausgehandelt. Aber ansonsten ist das Parlament der einzige Ort, wo ich Hoffnung sehe für ein Europa. Deswegen muss da einfach auch im Sinne von der Zukunft dieses europäischen Projektes einfach darauf schauen, dass man sich nicht unter den Teppich kehren lässt. Und wie gesagt, das war sicherlich mit Roaming auch nochmal schwierig, weil das ist halt einfach ausnahmsweise ein Thema, wo sich Europa-Abgeordnete profilieren können in den Medien. Aber wir können uns ja auch vielleicht mal kurz das Abstimmungsverhalten anschauen. Man hat schon auch gesehen, ausnahmsweise, die SPD ist fast nicht umgefallen. Also die SPD war groß, war mit 22 Stimmen dafür und nur einer Enthaltung und einer Gegenstimme. Und es waren schon auch so, vom Ergebnis her merkt man, wir sind durchgekommen mit unserer Kritik. Und es gab sogar einen CDU-Abgeordneten, der für die Änderungsanträge geströmt hat.
Ui, wer war das?
Oh mein Gott, suche ich die raus. Lass uns mal weiter reden, muss ich selber nachschauen. Also ich kann dir die Frage jetzt aber auch nicht beantworten, wie man dieses grundsätzliche Problem lösen kann. Es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, das eine Lösung braucht. Weil wie gesagt, ich glaube, bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung können wir in genau dieselbe Problematik reinlaufen. Und bei vielen anderen Themen natürlich auch, wo es um Bürgerrechte versus staatlichen oder Industrieinteressen geht.
Halleluja, dann können wir uns ja auf die nächsten schlechten Neuigkeiten aus Europa eh gefasst machen. Manne, vielleicht eine vorsichtige Frage. Hast du jemals irgendwie, gibt es, sind Beispiele überliefert von etwas, was irgendwie von der EU kam, das irgendwie wohldurchdacht und mit intendierten Konsequenzen war?
Also jetzt im Sinne von fertigen Dingen, die dann auch Realität wurden.
Ja genau, also gute Ideen gibt es da ja zuhauf.
Mein Gott, du stellst schon wieder Fragen, auf die ich keine Antwort weiß.
Wir beantworten die Frage jetzt einfach nicht.
Also die Software-Patente haben sie verhindert damals, aber ich weiß nicht ob Verhinderungen zählen, wenn schlechte Ideen nicht kommen.
Also wenn sie von einer völlig beschissenen Idee abgelassen haben, würde ich sagen, ein halber Punkt. Ein ganzer Punkt gibt es für eine gute Idee, die konsequent durchgezogen wird und die auch dann die intendierten Konsequenzen hat. Da gilt jetzt nicht dieses irgendwie wir verbieten, was weiß ich, Olivenöl in offenen Flaschen in Restaurants oder so. Was ja dann auch nichts geworden ist. Also wir überlassen das mal als Aufgabe für die Hörerschaft, vielleicht Beispiele für erfolgreiche und schöne EU-Regulationen.
In den Kommentaren zu sammeln. Aber auch irgendwie ein gutes Beispiel, diese ganze Nahrungsmittelkennzeichnung, dass du jetzt irgendwie auf den Restaurant-Speisekarten stehen hast, wenn da irgendwelche Allergene drinnen sind, ist auch etwas, wo man sich vielleicht mal denkt, wozu brauchen wir das? Aber wenn man mit Leuten spricht, die wirklich Nahrungsmittelunverträglichkeiten haben, dann hilft denen das schon sehr. Und auch Veganer freuen sich da natürlich. Das heißt, das ist etwas Gutes, was von der EU gekommen ist. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das Gesetz zustande kam, aber der intendierte Effekt, der bei den Leuten ankommt, ist, glaube ich, ein guter.
Na, immerhin. Also sehen wir. Das ist doch schon mal fein. Das ist toll. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt. Wir danken dir für dieses Update und hoffen, dass du dieses Thema weiterhin mit diesem Einsatz und dieser unverbitterlichen Ruhe bearbeiten wirst.
Ja, nicht nur ich hoffentlich, weil ansonsten wird das nichts. Wie gesagt, das ist alles Teamwork. Ich bin schon wirklich persönlich an einem Punkt, dass ich sage, das ist natürlich auch ein Misserfolg von den NGOs und auch von mir, die da in der Kampagne drin sind. Ich muss sich vorstellen, vor allem ich bin da jetzt seit ein paar Jahren dabei. Edre ist noch seit viel, viel mehr Jahren im Hintergrund am Werken und großteils unsichtbar bei diesen Dingen. Für die ist das natürlich noch mal doppelschmerzhaft. Aber wie gesagt, auch dieser mehrdeutige Gesetzestext, wir haben noch eine Chance, den jetzt bei den Regulierungsbehörden noch mal festzuzuhören und wir werden weitermachen. Auch auf Safety Internet wird es weiter Informationen geben. Im Moment ist da jetzt noch nichts aktualisiert, weil wir uns erst Gedanken machen müssen, wie wir dieses Problem in 28 Ländern auf einer Behörde Druck auszuüben, wirklich sinnvoll angehen können. Aber es gibt da auch wieder Möglichkeiten, selber aktiv zu werden. Vor allem Menschen, die beruflich mit dem Internet zu tun haben, die mittelbar oder unmittelbar vor einer Abschaffung der Netzneutralität direkt betroffen werden, die können sich in der Konsultation für diese Guidelines von BEREC einbringen. Da gibt es bald mehr Infos dazu. Und möglichst viele Stimmen wären da wirklich toll. Ich erinnere nur noch mal in den USA, da waren es vier Millionen Kommentare an die FCC in der Konsultation der damaligen Netzneutralitätsregeln. In Indien war es eine Million Antworten für die Konsultation von der indischen Regulierungsbehörde. Wir müssen allein jetzt so zur Ehrenrettung in Europa 40.000 schaffen. Ansonsten können wir uns ja nicht mehr bicken lassen auf der ITU. Ja, gut, das war es von meiner Seite. Ich wünsche euch noch eine gute Sendung und auf bald.
Danke dir, Thomas.
Okay, das war Thomas. Und jetzt ist ja seitdem auch schon wieder einiges passiert. Es dauerte nicht lange. Und unsere Freunde von der Deutschen Telekom sprangen aus dem Busch. Und wie ich schon sagte, wollen uns die Katzenbilder wegnehmen. Und legte in einem Superartikel ein tolles Statement auf den Tisch, was schön zeigt, dass, ja, wer's Geisteskind eigentlich nun dieser neue Beschluss wirklich ist. Die ganzen Optimismus von Thomas in allen Ehren. Aber jetzt geht's auf jeden Fall gleich ans Eingemachte.
Timotheus Höttges, der Vorstandsvorsitzender der Deutschen Telekom, hat dann direkt am 28.10. die Tinte unter dem von Öttinger gefeierten Beschluss zur Netzneutralität war noch nicht trocken. So ungefähr. ZB ist es jetzt noch nicht unterschrieben, aber man versteht, was ich meine. Und dann legte er sofort los und sagte, ja, das war jetzt eine schwierige politische Aufgabe, denn die Fronten waren ja verhärtet, die Positionen waren teilweise fundamentalistisch und die Netzaktivisten begreifen das Netz ja als öffentliches Gut. Und jetzt zum Glück...
Und es sei neutral.
Genau, so Quatsch, ja.
Also in Anführungsstrichen.
Und jetzt feiert er also quasi, dass selbstverständlich das beste Effort weiterlaufe, aber dass man eben Spezialdienste anbieten könnte. Also genau das, wovor alle immer gewarnt haben, hat er dann sofort auch bestätigt.
Da meint er ja vor allem auch noch sehr deutlich, gegen unseren Wunsch gibt es jetzt Regeln zur Netzneutralität.
Ja, um noch so diesen leichten Spin reinzubringen, wie wir wurden ja in Fesseln gelegt.
Viel mehr Regulierung.
Ja, stark, da muss man sich auch geschlagen geben, das und so.
Aber die Spezialdienste, das lässt ja nun wirklich die Sonde aufgeben, weil jetzt sind endlich innovative Internetdienste möglich.
Ja, gab es vorher nicht.
Das wäre schon auch noch gegangen, aber jetzt ist trotzdem halt noch immer noch alles drin.
Er schreibt, es bleibt in Zukunft möglich, innovative Internetdienste zu entwickeln, die höhere Qualitätsansprüche haben, als wäre das vorher nicht möglich gewesen. Also es wird auch in Zukunft möglich bleiben. Das sind die sogenannten Spezialdienste. Aha, ich dachte, sowas gab es noch gar nicht. Warum braucht es diese Spezialdienste im Netz? Das Internet ist vielfältig und bringt Dienste hervor, an die bis vor kurzem noch niemand gedacht hat. Das fängt bei Videokonferenzen und Online-Gaming an und geht über Telemedizin, die automatisierte Verkehrssteuerung und selbst steuernde Autos bis zu vernetzten Produktionsprozessen der Industrie. Inzwischen schämt er sich also noch nicht mal, mehr Videokonferenzen und Online-Gaming dazu zu nennen. Früher ging es ja nur um Telemedizin. Gemeinsam haben diese Dienste, dass sie andere teilweise höhere Qualitätsanforderungen haben, als das einfache Surfen oder die E-Mail, die auch ein paar Millisekunden später ankommen kann. Ja, jetzt alte Geschichte. Eine Videokonferenz sollte beispielsweise auch zu Stoßzeiten im Netz nicht ins Stocken geraten. Das wollen wir doch nicht. Deshalb muss die Möglichkeit bestehen, dass die Daten empfindlicher Dienste im Stau Vorfahrt bekommen. Das ging immer. Das haben sie ja auch gemacht. Ich erinnere nur daran, das war dann dieses Quality of Service, das die Telekom eben erkennt. Ah, unser Kunde möchte da ein Video schauen. Das stellen wir jetzt mal schneller durch, weil das ist zeitkritisch. Und die E-Mails machen wir halt langsamer. Das Entscheidende ist nicht, auf Basis der Art des Dienstes, im Sinne und im Interesse des Kunden, den Traffic zu managen. Das ist nicht das Entscheidende. Das haben sie vorher schon gemacht. Und das ist auch wieder hier das alte Argument, wo sie immer wieder diesen Vergleich bringen. Und da sagt er auch, glücklicherweise, so ehrlich ist er, schon heute ist Qualitätsdifferenzierung im Netz längst gelernte Praxis. Ja, das tun Internetprovider. Das tun sie in ihrem und in unserem Interesse. Nun schwenkt er aber natürlich um. Und jetzt wird es krude. Da muss man sehr genau hinschauen. Dann sagt er, Nutzer können selbst entscheiden, wie viel Service sie wollen und was ihnen dieser Service wert ist. So kostet beispielsweise mehr Speicherplatz für Mails extra. Genauso wie erweiterte Suchfunktionen bei Xing oder LinkedIn oder Videos in HD statt SD. Stimmt, stimmt alles. Wenn ich mehr als 50 Mails bei web.de speichern möchte, muss ich bezahlen. Wenn ich bei Xing irgendwie mehr suchen möchte oder eine Stellenanzeige schalten möchte, muss ich zahlen. Wenn ich Videos in HD bei Netflix schauen will, muss ich in Euro mehr zahlen. Aber um Himmels willen nicht an die Telekom. Und genau das wollen sie ändern.
Das ist wirklich so per viele, wie er in dieser ganzen Argumentation Netzzugang und Dienste dahinter in einen Topf wirft.
In Zukunft wird es eben auch die Möglichkeit geben, einen Dienst für ein paar Euro mehr in gesicherter Qualität zu buchen. Offen lässt er, in welche Richtung er jetzt dieses Geld kassieren möchte. Das ist keineswegs eine Revolution im Netz, sondern die natürliche Weiterentwicklung. Die Gegner von Spezialdiensten behaupten, kleine Anbieter könnten sich diese nicht leisten. Und jetzt kommt der Hammer. Jetzt wird es so richtig. Jetzt wird es zuckersüß. Das Gegenteil ist richtig. Gerade Start-ups brauchen Spezialdienste, um mit den großen Internetanbietern überhaupt mithalten zu können. Google und Co. können sich weltweite Serverparks leisten, damit die Inhalte näher zu den Kunden bringen und die Qualität ihrer Dienste so verbessern. Das können sich Kleine nicht leisten. Wollen Sie Dienste auf den Markt bringen, bei denen eine gute Übertragungsqualität garantiert sein muss? Brauchen gerade sie Spezialdienste? Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr krude. Wenn du heute einen Start-up gründest und schnelle Verfügbarkeit weltweit ein entscheidender Bestandteil deines Konzeptes ist, wie bei jedem Konzept, was du übers Internet machst, dann wendest du dich eben genau an zum Beispiel diese Akamai oder Amazon Cloud-Anbieter und nutzt deren Infrastruktur. Und zahlst an die für deren Dienstleistung Geld. Und auch das ist Geld, was der deutschen Telekom gerade verloren geht.
Weil sie ja selber keine konkurrenzfähigen Cloud-Dienste haben.
Genau. Und sie behaupten ja tatsächlich, dass die großen Anbieter das quasi selber machen würden und die deutsche Telekom die nicht abschriffen kann. Und jetzt schreibt er, also ne? Start-up kann sich nicht leisten, weltweite schnelle Verfügbarkeit zu bekommen. Hinweis, doch kann es. Es muss dafür an einen Anbieter bezahlen, der weltweit schnelle Verfügbarkeit garantiert. Das ist dann eben Akamai, Amazon oder irgendein sonstiger der großen Verfügbarkeits- und sonst was-Anbieter. Er behauptet, das wäre nicht so. Nach unseren Vorstellungen bezahlen diese Start-ups in Zukunft für Spezialdienste im Rahmen einer Umsatzbeteiligung von ein paar Prozent. Das wäre ein fairer Beitrag für die Nutzung der Infrastruktur und sorgt für mehr Wettbewerb im Netz.
Das ist wirklich jetzt überhaupt die Spitze.
Jetzt stell dir mal vor, du bist ein Start-up, und die Deutsche Telekom, ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele Millionen Festnetze im Mobilfonds-Kunden die gerade hat in Deutschland, aber so viele sind es auch nicht. Gemessen an der Weltpopulation und der Anzahl der Internetnutzer, die du erreichen möchtest, ist das ein lächerlich geringer Anteil. Sicherlich ein signifikanter.
Und vor allem nicht unbedingt deine Zielgruppe.
Kommt drauf an. Also wenn es deine Zielgruppe ist, dann kommt eben die Deutsche Telekom und sagt, gibt es noch ein paar Prozent vom Umsatz für das Erreichen nur dieser paar Millionen Kunden auf der Welt. Wenn das jetzt jeder macht, dann ist von dem paar Prozent Umsatz nichts mehr übrig.
Vor allem was hat der Umsatz eines Unternehmens mit der Dienstleistung der Telekom zu tun?
Nichts. Und da wird es interessant. Denn es ist offenkundig, was die Deutsche Telekom da versucht. Die haben gemerkt, ok, Internet ist irgendwie eine feine Sache, geht ab und so. Die Leute wollen das haben. Wir haben die Preise gesenkt. Wir reizen dieses Kupfernetz bis aufs Letzte aus. Aber wir müssen irgendwie traurig daneben stehen und zusehen, wie unsere Aktie nicht so geil abgeht, wie die von Google.
Trotz Manfred Krug.
Und nicht so geil abgeht, wie die von Netflix. Weil die innovative Ideen hatten, die unser Unternehmen nicht hatte. Und jetzt möchten wir von den zukünftigen innovativen Ideen den Start-ups Geld haben. Er behauptet ja jetzt, dass er von Google und den anderen kein Geld nehmen würde. Ich bleibe mal so bei seiner Argumentation. Selbstverständlich werden die anfangen, irgendwie zu versuchen, irgendwie Brückenzoll zu verlangen, auch von den großen Anbietern. Aber warum interessiert er sich hier so für die Kleinen? Und das Interessante, was ich sehe, ist, dass es eine Meldung gab, dass die Telekom ihren Start-up-Inkubator quasi jetzt gerade eingestellt hat und neu aufstellen möchte.
T-Ventures.
Genau. Und mein Eindruck ist, den ich bis jetzt nicht bestätigen kann, oder für den ich bis jetzt keinen Beweis habe, aber wo ich davon ausgehe, dass es das ist, was sie tun werden, ist, dass sie ihren Start-up-Inkubator umstellen auf, nicht du musst eine Umsatzbeteiligung haben, also du musst eine Umsatzbeteiligung an die Deutsche Telekom zahlen, weil sein Argumentation wäre ja, wenn du dann groß genug bist, dann verändert sich wieder das Kräftegleichgewicht und du musst nicht mehr an die Deutsche Telekom zahlen, weil dann bist du ja ein großer Anbieter, der es sich leisten kann. So behauptet er das ja. In dem Moment, wo du kein Start-up mehr bist, bist du ein großer Anbieter und dann kannst du es dir leisten. Und genau das wäre ja wieder fatal für die Deutsche Telekom, weil dann hätte sie quasi nur bei den Start-ups so ein bisschen was abgeschröpft am Anfang, bis sie groß genug sind, sich das Kräftegleichgewicht ändert. Und dann die Deutsche Telekom sagen müssen, ja, Mist, von dir können wir jetzt kein Geld mehr verlangen. Deswegen denke ich, was sie tun werden, ist, sie werden ihre Start-up-Venture-Kapitalist-Sache umbauen auf, wir können dir einen Spezialdienst anbieten, gegen Unternehmensbeteiligung. Und Unternehmensbeteiligung ist ja quasi dann auch Umsatzbeteiligung und ist ein Invest in die Zukunft des Unternehmens. Das ist das, was ich vermute, was sie tun werden.
Ja, aber die paar Start-ups, ob denen das irgendwie wirklich eine nennenswerte Einkommensquelle darstellt, zumal ja die Start-ups dann vor allem eins nicht mehr haben, eine gute Chance auf dem Markt.
Diese Start-up-Argumentation bringt der ja nur, weil es eben diese Initiative gab, Start-ups für Netzneutralität, die irgendwie europaweit Sturm gelaufen sind gegen diese EU-Regulation, weil die genau wissen, dass es ihnen an den Kragen geht. Und die Telekom weiß das auch. Und genau deshalb halte ich es für die, sag ich mal, wie nennt man sowas immer, wirtschaftlich geboten, wenn etwas besonders perfide ist. Würde ich sagen, ist es für sie jetzt wirtschaftlich geboten oder sinnvoll zu sagen, alles klar. Wir picken uns jetzt Start-ups raus und wir sorgen dafür, dass wir bei allen Start-ups eine brauchbare Unternehmensbeteiligung bekommen, dafür, dass sie unser Netz nutzen. Und dann können wir sinnvoll an denen partizipieren. Das ist das, was ich sicher bin, was sie hier tun. Weil überstimmt, es passt einfach zu genau zusammen. Aber wir müssen ja nicht nur über Start-ups reden.
Ja, vor allem, was mich erstmal interessieren würde, ist, was ist denn sozusagen Ihr Angebot?
Das Angebot? Du bist ein Start-up. Schön, es ist wunderbar, was du da machst. Sie wissen ja, dass sie nicht eine Umsatzbeteiligung von dir haben.
Nein, aber was bieten sie denn für die Kohle, die sie jetzt sozusagen bekommen?
Ganz normal, Venture-Kapitalismus, Investitionen. Und sagen, hallo, guck mal.
Nein, aber was bieten sie denn auf der Netzseite denn tatsächlich?
Na, einen Spezialdienst, dass dein Start-up funktioniert.
Ja, aber was? Genau, also was?
Die Frage verstehe ich nicht.
Naja, ich meine, was ist dieser Spezialdienst? Was wird im Netz der Telekom mit diesem Dienst anders gemacht, wenn du deinen Umsatz abgibst und sagst, hier Telekom.
Er wird nicht ausgebremst.
Ich kenne die da, ja.
Was heißt das? Andere Dienste werden zu seinen Gunsten langsamer gestellt.
Genau.
Und nicht andere Dienste, sondern andere Dienstanbieter. Das ist eigentlich das Entscheidende.
Ja, vor allem, sie werden ja nicht in dem Sinne schneller.
Nee, nee.
Sondern die anderen werden ja ausgebremst.
Genau, die anderen werden zu den Gunsten dieser Spezialdienste ausgebremst.
Ja, wenn er also sagt, man braucht ja Spezialdienste, um mit den anderen mithalten zu können, heißt das so viel wie, wir bremsen jetzt mal alle aus. Und wenn ihr nicht ausgebremst werden wollt, wir haben ja hier Wege recht, dann her mit der Kohle.
Genau, also Spezialdienste ist eine technisch. Nicht, eine begriff, zu dem es keine technische, äquivalente Sache gibt. Man könnte sich da unterschiedliche Sachen darunter vorstellen, wie zum Beispiel, okay, ihr stellt einen Cash von euren Inhalten bei uns direkt in den Schrank, sodass wir nicht mehr übers Internet gehen müssen. Man könnte sich darunter vorstellen, wir machen irgendwas, was gar nicht im Internet ist, sondern nur bei uns. Aber was effektiv damit gemeint ist, ist sowas wie der Spotify-Deal. Spezialdienst, du kommst übers Internet und wir zählen den Traffic nicht mit bei unseren Kundenabrechnungen. Und da ist übrigens auch genau das geschehen, was ich ja gerade gesagt habe, wie sie es machen werden. Telekom hat bei Spotify auch investiert. Das heißt, die wollen sich einfach nur Marktanteile bei diesen Start-ups sichern. Und werden das dadurch sicherstellen, dass ein Start-up ohne ihre Beteiligung im Prinzip einfach auch, zumindest in Deutschland, erstmal gar keine Chance hat.
Ja, also vielen Dank, Herr Oettinger. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen offiziell Schutzgeldzahlungen im Internet eingeführt. Und das wird bestimmt total gut funktionieren. Komischerweise sehe ich diese Balance zwischen dem Nutzen für die Industrie und dem Nutzen für die Gesellschaft noch nicht so ganz.
Gesellschaft nicht, Kunden. Ach so, cool.
Die Kunden von den Unternehmen.
Der ursprüngliche Tweet sprach von Business und Consumers. Also so ein Quatsch. Es gab noch in der Geschichte der Menschheit keine guten Neuigkeiten für beide. Also entweder du stärkst die Konsumentenrechte, die Verbraucherschutzrechte, oder du stärkst die Rechte der Unternehmen. Aber dass am Ende beide da stehen und sagen, je, das ist halt einfach grundsätzlich nicht der Fall. Weil das wäre in dem Fall, wenn du nichts machst, höchstens mal möglich, aber nicht dadurch, dass du irgendwie regulierst.
Auf jeden Fall ist es jetzt wichtig, glaube ich, hier auch mal klare Begriffe einzuführen, um diesen Sachverhalt auch zu beschreiben. Ich bin so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Ich fand den Begriff Internetmaut schon mal ganz gut, auch wenn er noch so ein bisschen was von Legitimierung hat.
Beide, alle Begriffe sind von der Deutschen Telekom im Prinzip erfolgreich dadurch verwirren, entkräftet worden, dass man sagt, wieso, du zahlst doch heute auch mehr für VDSL als für ADSL. Das heißt, das Zahlen für die Überholspur im Internet ist im Prinzip etwas, was den Menschen schon immer so prinzipiell klar war. Wenn es schneller sein muss, muss ich auch mehr bezahlen.
Auf der Autobahn nicht?
Ja, aber im Internet eben. Und das hat immer allen Leuten, den Leuten war auch klar, wenn ich schneller fahre, verbrauche das Auto mehr Sprit. Das Entscheidende, was die Telekom macht, ist, dass sie in die andere Richtung deiner Leitung anfängt, die Hand aufzuhalten. Das ist das wirklich Entscheidende. Das ist das, was in der öffentlichen Debatte nicht wirklich, auch in den Artikeln, nicht in der Form klar wurde. Die Deutsche Telekom oder die anderen Internetanbieter werfen ihre Kunden in die Waagschale und fangen an, die Anbieter zu erpressen.
Ja, und vor allem das machen jetzt alle.
Das werden jetzt alle tun.
Vodafone und Telefónica werden jetzt nicht lange auf sich warten lassen und alle machen so. Und dann frage ich mich, was ist jetzt eigentlich die blühende Landschaft, wenn jetzt ein Start-up sich quasi jedem einzelnen, nennenswerten Provider in Deutschland, und da wir dieses Unikopol von drei Providern haben, sind das halt alle drei, was heißt das dann? Das heißt, ich muss bei allen drei Providern meine Prozente abschmeißen, und das ist jetzt mal nur in Deutschland?
Nein, meine These ist, es wird nicht über Prozente laufen, indem sie dir am Ende des Jahres eine Rechnung stellen, sondern es wird dadurch laufen, dass sie in dein Start-up investieren und damit nicht sich die monatliche Rechnung zahlen lassen, sondern im Prinzip einfach sich einen Prozentteil am gesamten Cash-Out des Unternehmens sichern.
Ein paar Prozent des Umsatz, die Behauptung steht aber jetzt im Raum von der Telekom, und so muss man es dann glaube ich auch mal zusammenrechnen und sagen, ein paar Prozente pro Provider oder auch nur ein Prozent pro Provider, ich komme locker auf 100 Provider, die für mich relevant sind auf dem Planeten, wenn ich einen Dienst mache, fragt sich, wo dann der Rest noch herkommt.
Und die müssen, die sind die einzigen, die noch sind, von denen du Geld haben willst. Und dadurch sichern sie sich Unternehmensanteile an den Dienstleistern im Internet. Weil du hast quasi Provider und du hast auf der anderen Seite Unternehmen, die ein Schweinegeld damit verdienen, Dinge im Internet anzubieten. Und die Provider stehen da und sagen, Scheiße, wir haben hier Milliarden investiert. Okay, hören wir auf. Aber hier liegt eine ganze Menge Kupfer in der Erde. Hier wurde eine Investition getätigt, wenn auch nicht von uns. Aber hier wurde eine Investition getätigt.
Wir schröpfen jetzt mal ab.
Und wir möchten die gerne abschröpfen. Und woanders sitzen irgendwie fünf Mann vor ihrem iMac und schreiben eine Uber-Webseite oder eine Airbnb-Webseite oder ein YouTube. Und die sind jetzt irgendwie alle ganz reich. Und das geht ja wohl so nicht. Weil, wenn wir nicht da wären, dann würden die auch nicht so viel Geld verdienen. Und da wollen sie natürlich sich jetzt irgendwie die Zukunft sichern. Wenn ihr erst mal überlegt, was die Deutsche Telekom für ein Geld hat und dass sie im Prinzip keine nennenswerte Innovation, gerade in diesem Internet-Service-Bereich, jemals hinbekommen haben, dann ist natürlich klar, dass sie jetzt versuchen, auf diese Weise da irgendwie zukunftsfähig zu werden. Das ist ganz interessant, als ich hier diesen Artikel gelesen habe, dass T-Venture eben jetzt eingestellt wird und es einen Nachfolger geben wird, weil sie ihre Startup-Finanzierung umkrempeln. Da steht dann so drin, in seinen fast zwei Jahrzehnten der Geschäftstätigkeit hat sich T-Venture an zahlreichen Technologie-Startups beteiligt. Im Portfolio befinden sich der Airbnb-Konkurrent Nineflats. Kenn ich nicht. Und Airbnb-Konkurrent hat schon drin, so kopierte Idee. Die Spiele-Schmiede Flair Games kenne ich nicht. Und dann mit dem Taxidienst My Taxi hatte die Telekom-Tochter im vergangenen Jahr einen bedeutenden Exit zu vermelden. Das heißt, da haben sie Kohle gemacht. Bei der Berliner Software-Schmiede Sechs Wunderkinder, die kenne ich, die haben irgendwie so eine völlig dysfunktionale To-Do-List, war T-Venture lange vor dem Verkauf an Microsoft ausgestiegen. Da haben sie sich auch verzockt. Also Venture-Kram im Start-up-Bereich ist nicht die Stärke der deutschen Telekom. Und sich einfach zu sagen, wenn du überhaupt irgendwas machst, dann musst du uns ein paar Unternehmensanteile geben, damit du die Qualität deiner Dienstleistung sicherstellen kannst. Das, glaube ich, ist das, was sie in Zukunft tun werden.
Ich muss mir mal wieder meinen Lieblingsfilm Brasil anschauen. Hübsche, schöne Stelle. Da steckt bestimmt Simmons dahinter. Der war schon immer der Meinung, dass die Leute für ihre Verhöre mehr bezahlen sollten. Ja, na gut, sehr viel mehr können wir da nichts zu sagen, oder? Haben wir noch Anmerkungen? Es ist traurig und es ist wirklich, muss ich sagen, es ist jetzt auch wirklich, diese Wortmeldung, die Konsensfindung im Minenfeld, wie sie es hier genannt haben, das ist einfach eine Frechheit.
Mich interessiert noch eine Sache, da könnten wir vielleicht noch ganz kurz darüber sprechen. Die haben diesen Mist gerade beschlossen, und der kann sich kaum halten, nach vorne zu rennen und zu sagen, haha, super, wir schröpfen jetzt ab.
Vor allem so richtig beschlossen ist es ja technisch noch nicht.
Und jetzt frage ich mich, welche Strategie sich in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit dahinter verbirgt. Ich bin mir nicht, also Disclaimer, es ist nicht ganz klar, ob die Deutsche Telekom jemals eine Strategie in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit hatte. Wenn du dir anschaust, was irgendwie gestern deren Pressesprecher getwittert hat, und wenn du dir anschaust, wie das Unternehmen in seiner Geschichte öffentlich agiert hat, ist nicht klar, ob da überhaupt jemals eine Strategie hinter war, wie dieses Unternehmen sich öffentlich gebarrt. Aber nehmen wir mal an, dass irgendjemand nachgedacht hat, bevor Tim Motheus Höttgens bloggen durfte bei der Deutschen Telekom und diesen Text geschrieben hat. Da wird unter Umständen vielleicht noch so einer im Raum gewesen sein, der gesagt hat, meinst du, das ist eine gute Idee? Ich meine, die feiern gerade, dass das EU-Parlament erzählt da gerade einen von Netzneutralität und wir strömen jetzt los und sagen, hehehehe, so, ne? Meinst du, das ist eine gute Idee? Und irgendjemand wird gesagt haben, jo, weil. Und da frage ich mich, ob die Strategie dahinter ist, zu sagen, jo, alles klar, dann machen wir jetzt einmal richtig Lärm, dann ist das Thema auch wirklich durch. Ja, also Augen zu, Zähne zusammenbeißen und einmal über uns ergehen lassen, dann haben wir es endlich hinter uns und können machen, was wir wollen. Weil im Prinzip würdest du sagen, würdest du eigentlich immer davon ausgehen, dass die Strategie sinnvoller ist, zu sagen, okay, Salamitaktik, alle kritisieren die EU-Entscheidung, dann lassen wir jetzt erst mal ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr gar nichts passieren, um den Kritikern ein bisschen Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen. Das wäre eigentlich die Taktik, die man erwarten würde. Und dann einfach in Ruhe zwei Jahre später die ersten Schranken zu ziehen und zu sagen, ja wieso, er ist doch, ich meine, dürfen wir doch sagen, seit Jahren rechtlich zulässig. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, was ihr Gedanke dabei ist, das jetzt schon rauszuballern.
Also mir fällt auch nichts zu ein, muss ich zugeben. Mir ist jetzt nicht klar, was nach diesem Weil hätte kommen können. Also was wird jetzt damit sozusagen befördert? Also was erfordert jetzt sozusagen auch noch eine eine Beschleunigung und auf wen soll das wirken? Soll das auf die Öffentlichkeit, ist es eher kontraproduktiv. Wahrscheinlich glauben die sozusagen sogar, dass man jetzt ihre Argumentation einfach so kauft. Ich glaube aber, dass in der politischen Debatte das jetzt nochmal schön Nahrung gegeben hat, weil jetzt im Prinzip alle sagen können hier, da. Und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass hier so, und sie sollten sich auch ordentlich erschrecken, dass so Szenen wie zum Beispiel Online-Gamer jetzt überhaupt erst aufwachen und feststellen, so, oh hoppala, wie was. Es war doch immer nur von ferngesteuerten Autos und Notoperationen im Kofferraum die Rede. Und jetzt auf einmal irgendwie Online-Gaming. Ich meine, wir reden einfach nur von niedrigen Ping-Zeiten und was irgendwie schon seit Ewigkeiten problemlos immer auch hat realisiert werden können. Das soll jetzt auf einmal Geld kosten. Und wer hat das jetzt zu bezahlen? Am Ende noch die Game Studios selber, dass ihr Spiel schnell spielbar ist?
Na ja, am Ende werden, also was bei sowas ja immer am Ende steht und deswegen ja auch meine Theorie mit dem, die wollen nicht Umsatz, sondern Unternehmensbeteiligung, ist, dass sich große marktbeherrschende Stellungen ergeben. Das heißt, es wird dann einen Online-Gaming-Anbieter geben, der in der Lage ist, weltweite Verfügbarkeit herzustellen. Es gibt die Alternative, dass du mit 100 Providern weltweit selber verhandelst. Und um quasi dann im Internet verfügbar zu sein, gibt es dann eben den einfachen Weg oder den schwierigen Weg. Du kannst mit jedem Internetprovider einzeln reden, die haben aber wahrscheinlich für die paar Mark 80, die sie bei dir verdienen können, gar kein Interesse mit dir zu reden. Das heißt, es werden sich dann große marktbeherrschende Konzerne oder Konzerngruppen herausbilden, die im Prinzip alles, was da irgendwie geschieht, untereinander aufteilen. Das hast du beim Fernsehen ja im Prinzip auch. Da hast du große Sendergruppen, die dann eben unterschiedliche Sender für jeden Geschmack irgendwie machen. Und dann gibt es ein paar Satelliten, oder zwei oder drei Satellitenbetreiber, bei denen du eben die Slots buchen kannst. Und das war es dann. Da ist es dann vorbei mit der Vielfalt. Also diese Zeit, dass einzelne Unternehmen oder einzelne Start-ups, was weiß ich, Dienste buchen müssen oder sowas, das wird eine vorübergehende Phase sein. Das Endergebnis wird so die Fernseh-isierung der Diensteanbieter und Leitungsanbieter sein, wo es dann einfach einige wenige große gibt, denen alles gehört, die alles kontrollieren. Die haben doch kein ernsthaftes Interesse an irgendeinem Spargeschäft, wo sie Einzelabrechnungen pro Monat schicken. Den geht es darum.
Was ist jetzt die Drohkulisse, die ich als potenzielles Start-up, mit der ich mich konfrontiert sehe? Was genau habe ich konkret zu befürchten, wenn ich mich nicht mit der Telekom ins Bett lege? Das ist sozusagen die Frage. Und ist das, was sie dann androhen, entspricht es auch tatsächlich den Interpretationen, die dieses potenzielle neue Gesetz auch ermöglicht? Thomas hat ja schon gesagt, es ist ja sozusagen die Schwammigkeit der Formulierung ist das, was an vielen Stellen uns auch stört. Die Schwammigkeit der Formulierung kann aber eben sowohl zu der als auch zu der Interpretation führen. Und wenn halt jetzt die Aussage der Telekom so zu verstehen ist, wir schrauben jetzt erstmal alles runter, wir sorgen sozusagen für Stau. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch das Wort Stau ist ja sehr interessant. Also aha, bei euch gibt es Stau. Ihr habt so ein langsames Netz, dass da Stau herrscht und ihr wollt jetzt aber auch alle im Stau belassen und wer aus dem Stau raus will, der muss sozusagen seine Überholspur bezahlen. Und ja, wie viele Leute, könnte die Bezahlung an sich für den Dienst nicht schon bedeuten, dass gar keiner mehr im Stau steht? Ist das nicht der eigentliche Sinn dieser ganzen Bezahlung? Muss ja eure Infrastruktur nicht entsprechend aufbauen, dass es einfach gar keinen Stau gibt? Und was heißt denn das dann eigentlich? Heißt das, dass da eben bestimmte Dienste dadurch automatisch diskriminiert werden? Das ist wiederum untersagt von der neuen Regelung.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Die Regelung besagt, es gibt ein grundsätzliches Internet, in dem ist Best Effort. Und alles, was darüber ist, was diesem Best Effort Prinzip nicht genügen darf, mag, will, das ist ein Spezialdienst und diesen darfst du anbieten. Und keiner sagt, 90 Prozent deiner Leitungskapazität muss für Best Effort reserviert sein. Kannst sehr problemlos sagen, alles klar, wir haben, was weiß ich, im Schnitt zum Kunden 50 MBit. Davon sind erst mal, je nachdem, wie es läuft, 90 Prozent für Spezialdienste reserviert. Wenn der Kunde dann nur Best Effort nutzt, also ich, Tim, wo ging ich mich wehren will, ist immer wieder auf diese technische Ebene zu gehen. Darum geht es denen doch überhaupt nicht. Immer wieder dieser Stau, Vorfahrt, Autobahn, sonst was Vergleich. Bullshit. Denen geht es darum, dass sie an der anderen Seite mitpartizipieren wollen. Es gibt nachweislich keinen nennenswerten Stau. Das hatten wir vor zwei Jahren, als es irgendwie um die Drossel Com ging, besprochen. Es gibt irgendwie keine nennenswerte Auslastung der Kapazitäten. Wenn es die gibt, dann investieren sie da rein, dass ihnen das nicht mehr passiert. Es geht nicht um ein existierendes Problem, das sie jetzt managen müssten. Sie managen das die ganze Zeit. Es geht darum, dass sie an der anderen Seite, dort wo die Anbieter sind, die Hand aufhalten wollen und da Geld mitverdienen wollen.
Ja klar, aber die Frage, was ist die konkrete Drohkulisse? Das müssen ja nun Leute auch darauf eingehen.
Das wirst du dann schon sehen, wenn auf einmal die ganze Zeit Verstopfung im Internet ist.
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, ob diese Art von Best-Effort, die sie dann machen, weil im Prinzip kann das ja so sagen, diese Drohkulisse kann ja auch nur funktionieren. Du kannst jetzt noch mal beim Schutzgeld Gedanken bleiben. Du kannst von Laden zu Laden laufen und sagen, ja hier bist du mal schon hier, schöner Laden und so. Dann musst du aber auch irgendwann mal deine Trupps da reinchecken. Du musst halt auch irgendwie mal das Glas zersplittern lassen, bis diese Drohung auch ankommt. Sprich, es muss auch irgendwie Wirkung erzielt werden und die muss real durchgeführt werden. Sonst wird diese Drohung halt auch nirgends wo hinführen, nur weil jetzt die Telekom einen Blogpost veröffentlicht hat, zirken ja noch nicht alle gleich ihre Brieftasche. Und wenn das passiert, in welcher Ausprägung auch immer, dann wird es einfach ein Prüfstein sein, zu sagen, ist das noch best effort, was hier stattfindet? Erfüllt das überhaupt diese nicht definierten Kriterien? Oder sind das jetzt schon Blockaden, die eigentlich nicht zulässig sind?
Und wie weißt du das nach, abgesehen davon, dass es keine Blockade ist? Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie ich das nachweise, wenn ich jetzt auch noch nicht weiß, was die konkrete technische Maßnahme ist, die Telekom gedenkt zu ergreifen. Das werden wir dann halt sehen. Ich sage nur, das kann halt auch alles noch juristisch in den Seilen hängen. Ich greife Thomas Optimismus, den er in seinem Gespräch mit dir geäußert hat, auf, kann sein. Und die Debatte muss halt geführt werden, dass darauf jetzt auch ein strenger Blick gerichtet werden muss. Was machen die Telekom-Unternehmen? Was macht das Telekom-Oligopol in Deutschland und in anderen Ländern in Europa, die ja alle ihre Oligopole haben, dieser nicht wirklich freie Markt? Was tun die jetzt und ist das stadthaft? Da muss halt jetzt einfach gegen vorgegangen werden im Hinblick darauf, dass das jetzt erstmal so, wie es beschlossen wurde, auch verabschiedet wird.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Es bleibt zu hoffen, dass dem guten Herrn Höttges dieser Blogpost nochmal irgendwann bitterlich leid tun wird.
Kann er jetzt im Prinzip jetzt schon. So, jetzt schalten wir zu den anderen Spezialdiensten, die mit Agus-Augen aus dem Keller beobachtet wurden. Herr Graulich.
Herr Graulich hat jetzt sein Report vorgelegt. Der Sonderermittler des NSA- Untersuchungsausschusses, der jetzt beim BND gesessen hat. Und das ist in der Tat interessant. Also der hat einen 300-seitigen Bericht wohlgeschrieben, von dem du so um die 260 oder was öffentlich sogar einsehen kannst. Ich guck mal ganz kurz.
Es gibt drei Varianten von diesem Bericht. 263 Seiten. Drei Varianten. Eine fürs Kanzleramt, VS eingestuft, eine für den Untersuchungsausschuss, den NSA-UA, auch VS eingestuft und den, den man sich runterladen kann, den wir auch verlinken. Für alle. Das heißt, da fehlen dann so ca. 40 Seiten.
Aber das war die Seiten. Ich hab den, der ist erst vor kurzem veröffentlicht worden. Ich hab da jetzt mal reingeschaut. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal interessant. Ich werd den heute lesen. Nochmal. Also ich hab jetzt mal von vorne nach hinten lesen. Ich hab jetzt mir so die Teile angeschaut, Selektoren, wo er dann so darüber spricht, was er da so auch an Material hatte. Er hatte also unterschiedliche Selektorenlisten von unterschiedlichen Zeiträumen, wo sie dann eben aufgetaucht sind. Und das ist dann die sogenannte 2000er, die sogenannte 2005er. Und dann der Nachfund 1. Und hast du alles nicht gesehen, auch in unterschiedlichen Formaten. Das hat er dann auch immer beschrieben, was da so vor ihm liegt. Und hat dann so tabellarisch aufgedröselt die Übersicht der Zuordnungen, der sogenannten Ablehnungsliste für Internetselektoren, wo er dann irgendwie drin stehen hat, so ok, das sind deutsche Grundrechtsträger in Deutschland, das sind deutsche Grundrechtsträger in den EU-Staaten, das sind deutsche Grundrechtsträger in den Five-Eye-Staaten, das ist die einzige Spalte in der Zeit, in der nix steht, im sonstigen Ausland, Mitglieder der Bundesregierung 0, Bedienstete des Bundes 0, Mitglieder des Bundestages 0, Mitglieder anderer Verfassungsorgane 0, deutsche Vertretungen im Ausland 4, dann eben Verstoß gegen deutsche Interessen und so weiter. Das ist alles sehr aufgedrückt, auf jeden Fall alles sehr interessant und völlig unerwartet. Da hätte man jetzt nicht mitrechnen können. Kommt er zu dem Schluss, dass die NSA gegen den Vertrag verstoßen hat, indem sie diese Tausenden von Selektoren, die alle irgendwie gegen deutsche Interessen oder Grundrechtsträger gerichtet waren, dort eingepflicht hat. Da denkt man sich auf, welche vertragliche Basis war das denn nochmal? Ergemeint ist das Memorandum of Agreement von 2002, wo die vertragliche Basis für die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den beiden Geheimdiensten gelegt wurde. Und genau auf dieses Memorandum bezog sich ja zuletzt auch 2015, im April, eine Stellungnahme der Bundesregierung, in der gesagt wird, man hatte nach wie vor jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass hier eine massenhafte Aufspähung stattfinden würde oder so. Und ja, in diesem Report haben wir jetzt irgendwie so 70 Prozent der aussortierten Selektoren sind europäische Regierungseinrichtungen.
Also 70 Prozent der graulich vorliegenden Selektoren, die vermutlich die Selektoren sind, die vom BND aus dem, was die NSA rübergereicht hat, rausgenommen worden sind.
Ich wehre mich gegen das Wort Vermutung, vermutlich, weil wir haben jetzt in den Bericht geschaut und so, wie ich das sehe, ist das, er hat quasi nicht reine NSA-Selektoren vorgelegt bekommen, sondern nur das, was der BND schon aussortiert hatte.
Genau.
Das ist mein Verständnis von seiner Schilderung der Beweismittel, die er dort jetzt eingesichtet hat.
Also, wir müssen, man muss dazu sagen, es ist sozusagen in allen Berichten sehr unklar formuliert, was denn nun wirklich der eigentliche Umfang ist, der jetzt hier begutachtet wurde, aber das ist das, wovon wir jetzt ausgehen.
Wie gesagt, er beschreibt da jedes Beweisstück, was er eingesehen hat, sehr detailliert. Ich habe da bis jetzt keinen Hinweis darauf gefunden, dass er irgendwie einen vollen Zugriff auf die Selektoren hat. Dann sagt er, 70 Prozent der aussortierten Selektoren betreffen europäische Regierungseinrichtungen, dann viele deutsche Ziele, von denen 16 Prozent Telekommunikationsunternehmen waren. Er bemängelt dann, dass die Prüfung der Selektoren von Seiten des BND auch nicht systematisch genug war. Aber insgesamt zeichnet sich da genau dieses Bild ab, von dem eigentlich immer die spezifisch genug Rede war.
Also unter anderem waren halt Telefonnummern mit 0049 vor Wahl sozusagen in diesen Selektoren drin. Das kann doch keiner ahnen, dass das jetzt ein deutscher Anschluss ist, oder? Also, es ist, aber.de-Email-Adressen haben sie alle schon raus sortiert, aber naja, 0049, das haben wir jetzt übersehen.
Und dann gibt es noch eine schöne Hinweise, wie zwei Drittel aller EU-Mitgliedstaaten sind betroffen. Und 70 Prozent der Selektoren haben die EU betroffen. Und diese Selektoren betreffen wiederum zwei Drittel aller EU-Mitgliedstaaten. Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich so, was ist mit dem restlichen Drittel? Die befinden sich dann wahrscheinlich in dem Teil der Selektoren, wo die, wo sie durchgelassen wurden, wo keiner geschaut hat. Und er erkennt völlig überraschend technische und organisatorische Dezizite. Beim BND und ein Vertragsbruch von Seiten der NSA. Er ist halt ein Jurist. Aber am Donnerstag, den 5.11. ist er glaube ich im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Das wird sicherlich eine sehr interessante Sitzung dann. Wenn du sowas hast, dann verunsichert mich das.
Wir schreiten voran.
Können wir gerne machen.
Gut, weil wir müssen uns ja noch über das Schlammcatchen unterhalten.
Ja, wir haben letzte Woche ja schon kurz darüber glaube ich berichtet. bild.de hat jetzt einen Adblocker-Blocker, der nicht so wirklich funktioniert und ein YouTuber hatte dann gezeigt, wie man trotz Adblocker den Adblocker-Blocker auch noch mitblocken kann und dann die Seite sieht, aber nicht die Werbung. Während noch letzte Woche schon erklärt, dass der Axel Springer-Verlag dies als eine wirksame, die technische Umgehung eines wirksamen Urheberrechtsschutzes interpretiert.
Eine Formulierung, die sich ursprünglich mal auf die Verschlüsselung auf DVDs bezog?
Ich weiß nicht, also inhaltlich ist sie neutral, aber sie bezog sich, glaube ich, viel mehr. Das war der Auslöser für diese.
Also diese Formulierung hat auf jeden Fall auf diesen Verschlüsselungsschutz gegriffen. Das ist klar. Dafür war sie gemacht und jetzt wird sie halt noch mal aus der Schublade gezogen für, ja, für das hier. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie sehen die Gerichte das?
Und jetzt haben sie es geschafft. Nicht nur gegen den YouTuber haben sie eine Abmahnung geschickt mit Unterlassungserklärung und Kostennote, wie man das so macht. Der setzt sich jetzt zur Wehr. Also er sagt, ich unterschreibe die Unterlassungserklärung nicht und ich zahle das Geld nicht. Das heißt, das geht vor Gericht. Und dann haben sie gegen den Betreiber von Adblock Plus, die IO., Firma IO., ich weiß nicht, ob es die GmbH heißt oder nicht, aber gegen IO., eine einsweilige Verfügung erwirkt, in der Adblock Plus untersagt wird, die Build-Smart-Funktion über die Verbreitung von Programmcodes auszuhebeln. Die Argumentation ist, die Adblocker-Sperre sei eine Software-Verschlüsselung, deren Umgehung nach Urheberrecht unzulässig ist. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, das ist nicht wirklich eine Verschlüsselung, also da ist dann auch wieder vorsichtig, muss man natürlich gucken, welchem Richter man da was erzählt hat. Ich habe auch den Originaltext, die dieser 1-2-Ligen- Verfügung nicht vorliegen, aber sie haben also IO-Ärger gemacht und die haben dann daraufhin, erstmal, weil es eine 1-2-Lige Verfügung ist, da musst du ja Folge leisten, also wenn eine Abmahnung heißt, pass auf, wenn du das jetzt nicht machst, dann gehen wir vor Gericht, dann wird das teuer und eine 1-2-Lige Verfügung ist quasi so ein Noturteil des Gerichtes zur Gefahreneindämmung und das hat dann so zu erfolgen, kannst da auch vor Gericht gehen, dem musst du aber erstmal entsprechen und das hat AIO auch gemacht und hat dann entsprechende Posts in ihrem Forum entfernt, in denen quasi Menschen darüber diskutiert haben, wie man diese, wie ein Filter aussehen muss und dann Dann haben wir dann auch den juristischen Weg eingeschlagen. Dann sagen sie aber noch dazu, ja klar ist jedoch, dass die rechtliche Auseinandersetzung über die grundsätzliche Zulässigkeit von Adblockern durch diese ein-zweilige Verfügung nicht berührt wird. Und die Frage ist eben, ob diese Interpretation auf dem Urheberrecht so zulässig ist oder nicht. Und ich hatte ja in der letzten Folge schon so ein bisschen erklärt, dass man das durchaus wahrscheinlich so interpretieren kann, wenn man sagt, es gibt technische Schutzmaßnahmen, die die Art der Nutzung des Werkes betreffen. Also schwierig, ja. Aber es gab vor einiger Zeit einen Urteil, wo ProSieben Sat. 1 gegen Adblock Plus vor Gericht stand. Und da wurde vom Landgericht München formuliert. Und es war irgendwie im Mai diesen Jahres. Die Klärin macht ihr Angebot weltweit, also ProSieben Sat. 1, ohne technische Beschränkungen, öffentlich, zugänglich und verzichtet auf jegliche Anmeldung, Registrierung oder Bezahlschranken. Die bloße Nutzung dieses Angebots mit der damit einhergehenden Vervielfältigung im Arbeitsspeicher ist daher, unabhängig von der anders lauten Bitte der Klägerin auf ihren Webseiten, auch für Nutzer mit eingeschalteten Werbeblocker als bestimmungsgemäße und erlaubte Nutzung anzusehen. Bezugnehmend darauf argumentiert Springer nämlich jetzt. Aha, also das Entscheidende ist, verzichtet auf Anmeldung, Registrierung oder Bezahlschranken und BILD hat ja genau das jetzt. Sie sagen ja, dieses BILD Smart, BILD Plus. Sie haben jetzt quasi diese urheberrechtlich geschützten Werke und Leistungen, auch mit einem bezahlpflichtigen Abonnement oder Anzeigen der Werbung und sie versuchen jetzt quasi, auf diese Rechtsprechenden des Landgerichts München zu reagieren und sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt eine Maßnahme gefunden, die die nicht in unserem Interesse liegende Nutzung unserer Seite verhindert und deren Umgehung betrachten wir als Verstoß gegen diesen Paragrafen. Es bleibt spannend und wie gesagt, bei Adblock Plus ist auch wieder die Sache, das ist auch jetzt nicht das feinste Unternehmen, aber ich bin da inzwischen, da wir ja immer vor unklaren und Gesetzestexten, die viel Interpretationsspielraum lassen, gewarnt werden, inzwischen auch vorsichtig, was diesen durchaus Interpretationen unterliegenden Gesetzestext angeht.
Du meinst, du bist jetzt vorsichtig in Bezug auf die Auslegung in diesem Fall. Ja klar, ich meine, Landgericht München und Landgericht Hamburg, das waren jetzt die beiden Instanzen, die jetzt hier beteiligt waren. Es überrascht mich wenig, dass das Landgericht Hamburg hier für ProSpringer argumentiert. Das Landgericht Hamburg ist ja in Urheberrechtsfragen bekannt für eine, wie soll ich sagen, recht verlagshäusern, recht offenherzig gegenüberstehende Rechtsprechung. Das ist jetzt nicht das erste Mal und das ist sicherlich jetzt hier auch nicht der letzte Schritt, weil ich mir auf der anderen Seite vorstellen kann, dass diese AO, das ist wirklich eine GmbH, durchaus noch die eine oder andere Instanz bemühen wird und jetzt hier nicht sofort kleinen Ballen geben wird. Weiß ich nicht. Dann ist halt auch nochmal jetzt der Sonderfall mit dem YouTuber, den wir an dieser Stelle vielleicht auch einfach nochmal loben können, für das beherzte nicht gleich den Schwanz einziehen, sondern der jetzt hier sagt so, nö sehe ich nicht so, freie Meinungsäußerung, was wollt ihr eigentlich? Ich habe jetzt hier kein nicht gegen das Urheberrecht verstoßen. Das wird auch nochmal sehr interessant sein, wie das ausgeht und ich denke, hier wird noch so einiges hin und her gehen. Also ich habe jetzt auch wirklich keine klare Meinung, wie das ausgehen kann, aber ich finde, das ist alles sehr fisch. Diese Frage, die ja jetzt im Prinzip hier von Springer aufgemacht wird, finde ich nichtdestotrotz auch sehr interessant. Als was ist denn sozusagen so ein Internetangebot einzuschätzen, wenn es so öffentlich im Netz ist und wenn da sozusagen noch dieses naja, ich würde ja auch gerne damit Geld verdienen und deswegen betrachte ich quasi die Werbung auch als mein eigenes urheberrechtliches Erzeugnis, weil genau genommen das, was urheberrechtlich geschützt ist, das ist ja sozusagen ihre Leistung und nicht die Werbung, die sie einblenden. Aber sie betrachten ja sozusagen die Internetseite in ihrer ganzen Darreichung quasi als urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk. Das ist ja hier so ein bisschen, wenn ich die Argumentation verstehe.
Nee, die Argumentation ist, wir bieten urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte an, einen Artikel. Und wir bieten diese urheberrechtlich geschützten Dinge an im Gegenzug oder unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Diese Bedingungen lauten, du bist BILD plus Abonnent. Und hast ein Login und kommst bei uns auf die Seite. Oder du kriegst eine andere Seite gezeigt, die mit Werbung versehen ist. Diese beiden sind die Nutzungsformen, die wir als Urheber zulassen oder intendieren. Nun stellen wir fest, dass Menschen weder das eine noch das andere tun. Nämlich sie bezahlen nicht, und erschleichen sich die Seite ohne Werbung.
Das heißt, sie führen eine Verletzung des Vertrages, des impliziten Vertrages.
Sie führen die Seite einer Nutzungsform zu, gegen die wir einen nicht wirksamen Schutz haben. Und dieser Schutz ist quasi eine Absichtsbekundung des Urhebers. Das ist ja immer dieses wirksame Schutz, das ist ja das Witzige da drin, aber dieser wirksame Schutz ist eine Absichtserklärung, eine technische Maßnahme, die das verhindern soll. Und die umgeht ihr, und damit verletzt ihr unser Urheberrecht.
Es gibt ja auch noch ein Statement von dem Startler, der meint, das ginge zu weit, weil wenn das mit dieser lockeren Formulierung so durchgeht, dann könnten halt Browser-Hersteller auch für Cookies und andere Umgehungen auch noch belangt werden. Dass sozusagen auch so gesetzte Tracking-Cookies und so weiter genauso als Bedingungen angesehen werden. Um die Nutzung sozusagen der Seite zu machen, das ist ja dann das nächste Fass, was damit aufgemacht werden würde und das könnte in der Tat noch mal den ganzen Ratten-Schwanz nach sich ziehen.
Das ist in der Tat richtig. Wenn sich da jetzt die falsche Rechtsprechung etabliert, dann können wir echt langsam mal bald mit dem scheiß Internet aufhören.
Das macht keinen Spaß mehr, aber das ist echt nicht mehr schön. Aber dafür gibt es ja dann noch andere Leute im Netz, die haben auch sehr innovative Ideen, wie man noch Geld verdienen kann im Internet.
Innovatives Geschäftsmodell. Ich bau einen Trojaner und wenn du ihn für mich bei anderen installierst und mir Geld bezahlst, dann lasse ich dich an den Datenteil haben, die dieser Trojaner von den anderen Leuten extrahieren kann. Also MyWare as a Service. Ich biete einen Trojaner zum Kauf an oder beziehungsweise die Nutzung meines Command-and-Control-Servers nach der Installation dieses Trojaners und lasse das Ganze von dir selektieren. Ein sehr appetitliches Geschäftsmodell, was dann in der Regel beworben wird, damit man jederzeit weiß, wo seine Geliebten sind. Also wird dann quasi so durch die Blume beworben als Baby-Phone. Oder kannst mal sehen, ob deine SMS angekommen ist, die du gerade geschickt hast oder solche Scherze. Und da gab es also einen Trojaner-Dienstleister, der das gemacht hat. Und bei den Kunden oder bei einigen seiner Kunden haben nun Hausdurchsuchungen stattgefunden, wo also die Nutzer dieses Angebotes jetzt in Probleme geraten. Spontan würde man sagen, ja, das ist doch prima. Dass diese Menschen, wenn sie andere gegen ihren Willen ausspionieren und diese Software einer illegalen Verwendung zuführen, dass sie dafür von der Polizei nun geärgert werden.
So sie denn das getan haben.
So sie denn das getan haben. Und genau dieser Teil der Beweiskette fehlt ja in dem Moment, wo du einfach nur Kunden dieses Unternehmens nimmst. Das ist deshalb so kritisch und so wichtig, weil wir ja relativ viel auf die Nutzung von Angreifertools angewiesen sind, um uns selber verteidigen zu können. Also alles, was mit IT-Sicherheit zu tun hat, muss angreifen können, muss Angreifertools nutzen können, um zu schauen, ob Schutzmaßnahmen wirksam sind. So werden zum Beispiel derartige Smartphone-Trojaner auch gerne von den Herstellern von Sicherheits-Apps oder Security-Produkten gekauft, um zu schauen, ob ihr Produkt gegen diese Art Angriff sicher ist. Es gibt durchaus legitime Anwendungszwecke für derartige Software. Und es fällt uns leider sehr schwer, Software grundsätzlich in Gut oder Böse zu trennen. Was mir da noch einfällt, ist diese... Ich habe in dunkler Erinnerung, dass in dem Urteil gegen Chelsea Manning dann die Rede davon war, dass sie ja WeGed genutzt hat, um diese Sachen zu scrapen. Die hatten ein kleines Special-Skript mit WeGed geschrieben, um diese ganzen Cables zu saugen. Und das dann darin eine Verletzung des, wenn ich mich nicht sogar täusche, DMCA oder CFAA, also Digital Millennium Copyright, ne, wahrscheinlich Computer Fraud and Abuse Act, also die Nutzung eines Hacker-Tools diagnostiziert wurde, weil sie eben nicht hingegangen ist und diese Cables einzeln runtergeladen hat, sondern sie hat dieses System gehackt, indem sie irgendwie einen kleinen Bash-Dreizeiler gemacht hat und alle Seiten automatisiert runtergeladen hat. Daran kann man auch wieder sehen, also WeGed ist einfach so ein Download-Tool. Ja, es ist sehr, sehr schwierig, es gibt natürlich Programme, die eher einer illegalen Nutzung zuträglich sind als einer legalen. Aber es ist grundsätzlich nicht am reinen Besitz des Programmes oder an der reinen Anwendung des Programmes zu beurteilen, ob das, was man damit tut, nun legal oder illegal ist. Und deswegen ist es sehr gefährlich, Software grundsätzlich in so eine legal, illegal, Hacker-Tool, Nicht-Hacker-Tool-Kategorie setzen zu wollen und darauf basierend polizeilich oder juristisch agieren zu wollen. Insofern wird dieser Fall spannend bleiben. Und er hat eben diesen ärgerlichen Teil, dass man sich denkt, er wäre irgendwie Trojaner auf Smartphones von engen Vertrauten installiert, weil um den da drauf zu kriegen, musste dieses Android-Telefon immer noch mal routen und den installieren. Und es gibt wahrscheinlich nur wenige Menschen, die das vertrauen haben, ihr Telefon längere Zeit dir zu geben und an denen du gleichzeitig das Interesse hast, sie auszuspionieren. Das heißt, es wird in der Regel zeigen Studien, dass sowas von Männern gegen ihre weiblichen oder männlichen Partner eingesetzt wird. Und natürlich ist das halt sehr, sehr schwaches Tennis. Und entsprechend auch illegal und sollte auch bestraft werden. Aber eben mit dieser Ermittlungsmethode, die da jetzt der Berichterstattung nach.
Da muss man schon noch ein bisschen mehr Feinheiten berücksichtigen.
Achso, da haben wir ja auch vielleicht noch ganz kurz empfehlen. Wir haben gestern Abend darüber gesprochen im Chaos Radio 217 mit dem Titel Professional Hackers.
Ja, mal wieder eine Sendung, die sich sozusagen mit dem Leben in der Security-Szene auseinandersetzt. Genau. Da kam das dann auch zur Sprache. Und noch ein paar andere Dinge. Eine Runde an einem Deal-Linus mit Frank Thies und Cibas.
Und Markus Richter, der Radio-Manager.
Ja, dann gab es noch eine kleine, vielleicht unbedeutende, aber trotzdem bemerkenswerte Entscheidung im EU-Parlament, wo man mal so ein bisschen, am Schluss hier nochmal so eine kleine positive Energie nochmal durchs Kabel jagen kann. Es gab nämlich einen Beschluss, der unter anderem auch eine Aussage darüber traf, wie denn das EU-Parlament meint, wie die Regierung der Europäischen Union mit etwa Snowden umzugehen hätten. Man muss gleich vorweg sagen, dieser Beschluss ist sozusagen ein Meinungsbild des EU-Parlament und in keiner Hinsicht irgendwie bindend oder zwingend. Aber trotzdem, es gab eine Mehrheit, eine sehr knappe Mehrheit, ich glaube, das war das 285 zu 281 Stimmen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz eine Mehrheit der EU-Parlamentarier, die sich eben für diesen Entschluss ausgesprochen hat, der dann im Prinzip sagt, dass es doch gefälligst dem Herrn Snowden ein, wie ist das formuliert, nicht unbedingt ein Asyl, aber zumindest Schutz geboten werden sollte.
Schutz vor der Auslieferung.
Genau. Was insofern sehr schwierig ist, als dass die ganzen europäischen Staaten, ich weiß nicht, ob das mit allen so ist, aber auf jeden Fall mit vielen und auf jeden Fall mit Deutschland in der Regel mit den USA ein Abkommen haben, was sozusagen Auslieferung eben möglich macht, wenn die USA das gerne möchte. Ja, das wurde dann auch von Herrn Snowden zur Kenntnis genommen, auf Twitter zumindest.
Hat sich gefreut.
Hat er sich kurz ein bisschen gefreut. Ich glaube, er macht sich nicht zu viele Illusionen über seine Situation und die Wirkung. Aber die Argumentation ist ja unter anderem dann auch in der Debatte so geführt worden. So, hier guckt mal, jetzt haben wir Safe Harbor gekippt. Jetzt war das sozusagen unser Anlass, das alles mal zu überdenken. Und es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das EU-Parlament jemals eine andere Haltung hatte. Na ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Ich meine, das Ergebnis ist knapp genug. Das Interessante daran ist, wenn jetzt, da die USA ja Auslieferungsabkommen mit den meisten europäischen Staaten haben, wenn jetzt ein Land sagt, wir werden Snowden nicht ausliefern, und der Snowden geht da hin und wird dann auch nicht ausgeliefert, dann wäre das eigentlich ein sehr, also das ist dann eigentlich ein Incident, weil dann wirst du ja vertragsbrüchig. So ein bisschen wie die NSA gegenüber dem BND. Könnte man dann sagen.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Ein Sonderermittler könnte halt dann feststellen, dass du vertragsbrüchig geworden bist. Das möchtest du natürlich nicht. Aber ich meine, ist natürlich schön, wenn im EU-Parlament mal wirklich zur Abwechslung was halbwegs Nettes entschlossen wird. Aber es ist auch wieder dran, dass das natürlich grundsätzlich ohne jegliche Konsequenz ist. Dass das EU-Parlament gesagt hat, wir fänden das ganz gut. Und wir erinnern uns, vor einem Jahr hat das EU-Parlament auch gesagt, wir fänden Netzneutralität ganz gut. Also, ja.
Und es mag vielleicht auch schwierig sein, für ein Land das mal durchzuziehen. Einfach zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt einfach. Aber da kann man sich ja auch mal breit aufstellen und sagen, wir schaffen das. Es ist schwierig, aber wir schaffen das. So, das war's für diese Woche. War auch lange genug.
Scheiße. Hier noch eine gute Nachricht. Wir sind jetzt vier Jahre alt. Stimmt.
Wir können also schon gehen und sprechen.
Ich habe wieder kein Geschenk bekommen von Tim. Da lacht er drüber.
Wo ist dein Geschenk für mich?
Ich habe das hier, aber ich gebe dir das nicht. Seit vier Jahren... Ich frage jedes Jahr hier ein Geschenk hin und...
Wartest du darauf, dass ich den ersten Schritt mache? Anstatt einfach mal voranzugehen mit deiner Art?
Was heißt voranzugehen mit deinem Geschenk?
Naja, wenn du so geschenkefreundlicher Mensch bist, und du dir eigentlich überhaupt nichts anderes darüber Gedanken machst, als mir ein Geschenk zu machen, dann mach das doch einfach.
Ich habe dir ein Interview mit Thomas geschenkt. So undankbar ist er.
Das ist aber hier wirklich ein sehr innovativer Spezialdienst, den du mir jetzt hier verkaufen möchtest. Müssen wir uns noch bedanken? Wir müssen uns noch bedanken.
Wir grüßen Georg und Hannes.
Wir grüßen und das war's, die 158. Und nächste Woche saugen wir dann mal wieder ein paar gute Nachrichten auf.
Bin ich ja immer sehr gespannt.
Ich auch.
So.